Do you remember how big
the world felt when we were younger?
Because my childhood was filled
with time travel and adventures.
I sat in awe of how flowers grew
from a simple seed.
I remember looking up
at the sky and wondering:
Was the Earth moving?
Was the sun moving? Or was I moving?
And I filled the rest of the time
by reading books about fantasy lands.
But slowly, the time travel
and adventures of my youth
became using my GPS
to figure out how much traffic
I'd inevitably be sitting in.
The flowers became the screen saver
to my laptop I spent way too much time on.
I only saw the sunrise when pulling
all-nighters to get work done.
And those fantasy lands, well,
those became essays and articles
from underfunded newspapers.
And yes, some of this is just
a part of growing up, necessary even.
But I realized the imaginative
and creative forces that drove me
had less and less space to thrive
in my young adult life.
And in being forced
to look at the world as it is,
I was missing out on the opportunity
to look at the world as it could be.
Now more than ever,
we live in a world
that requires of us an imagination
so that we can envision
what could be different.
And while I didn't come prepared today
to answer the world's largest problems,
I would like to make a case
for how one tool can help us
continue to build new worlds
and find our place in it.
Curiosity.
I don't have any fancy graphs
to show you all today,
but I would like to think
that I'm sort of an expert in the field
as my entire life has been a case study
in following my curiosities.
It started super simple.
My grampy and I
would reimagine and act out
the entire saga of The Odyssey
with my Polly Pocket dolls,
as one does at the age of four.
And around the age of five,
I asked for every religious book,
I mean every religious book.
Fast forwarding to 13,
I read my first short story
from the formidable James Baldwin,
and my life was forever changed.
Needless to say,
I was grateful to be surrounded
by a community of people
that honored my interests.
But as I got older,
I began to get confronted
by a big question:
Are you sure about that?
Now this was a question
I really could not escape.
In August of 2018, right as I was
embarking on my next adventure.
I was beginning
my freshman year at Harvard
right as my television show “Grown-ish”
began filming season two.
And I was at a crossroads, because acting
for me has been more than a career.
It's given me permission
to explore my fantasies.
I feel like I gain
another level of empathy
every time I step into
a different character's shoes.
But my education
has been equally as pivotal.
Because my education has fulfilled
my endless desire to know:
to know places, to know the events
that have shaped us,
the communities that have built us,
the obstacles that have tried to stop us,
the mistakes that haunt us.
But selfishly, to know about myself
and my place in the world.
So my two lifelong passions
were colliding,
and I was being told by academic advisers
and entertainment folk alike --
although no one on my team --
that there was no symbiotic relationship
between the two worlds.
I was searching for an "and,"
but I kept getting presented
an "either-or."
And I almost let those five words --
“Are you sure about that?” -- stop me.
But let me cut to the chase.
I'm speaking to you now as a Harvard alum
with a television show
going into its sixth season.
(Applause)
It's cool.
And while my college predicament
may have been unusual,
I do think this experience
is quite universal.
Because, one, I’m far
from the first person
to go to school while working.
But also I'd go so far as to say
all of us juggle multiple interests,
passions and jobs.
Yet there comes a moment on our paths
where we're expected to get serious,
to find our one thing, stick to it.
We're told that
our multiple areas of interest
that we are equally drawn to
are incompatible.
And hit with that all-too-familiar
“Are you sure about that?”
Suddenly we go from being expected
to know math and a language,
science and history,
to operating in this narrow silo
for the sake of becoming an expert
or really good at one thing.
I mean, think about how many times
we ask each other the question,
"What do you do?"
Which is really a proxy in my mind
for a much more pressing question,
"Who are you right now?"
Because what we do
is only a fraction of who we are.
And this culture of heralding expertise
means that our curiosities
are often mislabeled as distractions.
I would love to think through
what we could be missing out on
by not actively prioritizing
our curiosity.
Here, let me put it this way.
Curiosity has been a lifeline for me.
It's really easy to be 23 and a pessimist.
It doesn't take many observational skills
to see the deep flaws
and fissures of our world,
to see how close we remain
to these systems of oppression
we swear are behind us.
And when I say
I feel affected by these flaws,
I'm not just talking about
some existential "I have a degree
in a social science" kind of way,
but in the very real way
that it affects me and my family
and my community every day.
It's also easy to be 23
and struggle to find your place.
I remember so vividly being 16
and thinking that I could
change the world.
I was certain of it.
I was one voting initiative away.
I was one march away,
I was one panel away from real change,
the kind that lasts.
And I remember when that assuredness
was replaced by quicksand.
It felt as though the more I moved
and the more I struggled,
the more I sank into the overwhelm.
And I responded to feeling lost
by finding comfort in my expertise,
hiding behind this false
sense of certainty,
I really acted like I knew everything
there was to know.
I was suppressing my curiosity,
but I realized that made it so much easier
to pick apart every potential decision
rather than take action.
Now while I can't speak
for everyone's experiences,
from conversations I've had
with my peers and my mentors,
I know this feeling
isn't relegated to being 23.
Choosing to take on both college
and entertainment at the same time,
blending my two worlds,
was a necessary recommitment
to my curiosity.
I found such a joy in discovering
just how much I didn't know.
Lessons came from everywhere:
classes like hip-hop sampling,
on how neo soul and blues
became the basis to a new sound
taught me how media can be used
as a way of preserving legacy,
as a way of bringing
past cultures into the present.
Playing Tinker Bell gave me permission
to reignite my imagination.
My class on W.E.B. Du Bois
is where I discovered the name
for our television production company,
7th Sun.
And building a television set
and writers’ room
gave me the ability
to practice equitable hiring
within an archaic system in real time.
And in an independent study
created by Dr. Cornel West,
I learned my biggest lesson of all.
See, there are certain
elements of our society
that we deem as universal,
immovable truths,
when they're, in fact, subjective.
Not only are they subjective,
they're oftentimes responsible
for these systems of oppression,
for these dangerous
misconceptions about people,
for this feeling of stuckness,
this feeling like nothing can change.
And to me, these universal truths
can range from everything
as big as socioeconomic exploitation
to that "Are you sure about that?"
that stops you from going off
on your own and exploring.
Conversely, this means academics
and entertainment are most potent
in their abilities to demonstrate
alternate realities.
This lesson reinvigorated my love
for these two spaces
because I realized they'd always been
primed for imagination and exploration
and gave us the ability to explore
what can blossom from curiosity.
This perspective shift taught me
that I was thinking too small
because I thought the task at hand
was to merely alter these systems at play
rather than to imagine
entirely new ways of being.
Because the results of curiosity
are immeasurable.
From Galileo's reordering of the universe
to how the musician Prince
undefined masculinity for generations.
And oftentimes these discoveries
can jeopardize past ways of thinking.
I like to call the change that emerges
from blossomed curiosities rupture.
If tradition is this result of repetition,
then rupture is the introduction
of something fresh.
It's bridging together two spaces
often kept separate
for the sake of achieving new ends,
and it's of insisting
that there are possibilities
outside of the ones
we've been presented with.
But too often dreaming
is relegated to the academy
and to Silicon Valley, and to all of
these exclusive institutions.
When it is in fact the daily curiosities
of every one of us
that holds the most potential for rupture.
Now if you aren't convinced
just yet that you are
a universe-shifting change maker,
then it is my duty
as a history nerd to remind you
that most of these leaders
of these social change movements
that we credit with giving us
the world that we live in today,
change was not their day job.
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr was a preacher
paying attention to the works of Gandhi
across the ocean while reading Tolstoy.
But I also think of my own papa,
who used his position within education
to enfranchise Black children
in Madison, Wisconsin.
I think of my cousin, Anousheh Ansari,
who went from looking up
at the stars in Iran
to flying to the space station.
I think about the protesters in Iran
led by women and children,
putting their lives on the line
because they're curious
about what a society looks like
that values women, life and freedom.
(Applause)
Now if it isn't clear,
do you know what
the byproduct of curiosity is?
Possibility, surprise!
(Laughter)
Now I’ve graduated from Harvard,
and my television show is ending.
And a couple of years ago,
this really would have terrified me
to leave two spaces that I know so well.
But because I've built a life
centered on honoring my interests,
everything from the glockenspiel
to Octavia Butler,
I walk excitedly towards what's next
because I know somewhere between
the two lies my next adventure.
Chasing curiosity means that my purpose
is constantly unfolding in front of me.
All I have to do is pay attention.
And similarly, each and every one of us
have a special set of interests
that are totally unique to us,
like a thumbprint.
So please join me
in recommitting to curiosity.
Because honoring your so-called
distractions is an act of creating.
It's to sit in the grandeur
of all of our options.
It's to acknowledge
our infinite possibilities
when the world tries
to convince us it is indeed finite.
So refuse to let your world get smaller,
and let’s build new futures together.
Thank you.
(Applause)